I think now we're in year six of the
presidential race is everybody it is
doesn't it feel that way yep it goes and
goes and goes the latest is that
Democratic presidential candidates Amy
Klobuchar and Pete Buddha judge have
been sniping at each other on the
campaign trail
yeah man the battle for fourth place is
getting ugly what are they fighting for
her an astroid I love this story an
asteroid traveling through our solar
system is made apparently of iron
platinum and gold and it's valued at
over 700 quintillion dollars yes yeah no
one knows much about the asteroid except
that it's supporting Mike Bloomberg for
president no conclusively a bit of a
soft response there I better it I'm
gonna really notch it up for this last
one I was just letting you settle in a
little bit right that's all right
letting everybody get comfortable and
then I hit him with the third
a fan is suing Madonna for pushing back
the start time of her concert two hours
yeah yeah it's true yeah yeah yeah the
fan said I can't stay up that late I'm
as old as Madonna
[Applause]